Kelly Ripa and her daughter have the
sweetest mother-daughter bond the live
with Kelly and Ryan co-host brought her
16 year old daughter Lola Consuelos with
her to the 2017 CNN Heroes all-star
tribute which Ripa was hosting with her
BFF Anderson Cooper the 46 year old mom
of three stunned in a long-sleeved
sequined black dress with matching pumps
while Lola looked pretty in pink with
pointy nude pumps and gold jewelry but
this isn't the first time the teen has
escorted her famous mom on the red
carpet in May the mother-daughter duo
turned heads at the 2017 New Jersey Hall
of Fame induction ceremony she made a
more recent appearance on her mom's
Instagram when Ripa assured fans that
the lit holiday pic was approved by her
daughter and in November Lola stopped by
live and helped her mom out in the
kitchen
what is Kelly like at home with you guys
by Kelly he means mom yes yeah she is
just so great
Lola also joined her dad Mark Consuelos
at the premiere for his flick nine lives
in 2016 walking a premiere walking a red
carpet or blue carpet with her dad who
starred in the movie come on that's got
to raise your cool factor it's cool I
like it I'm like you're actually kind of
cool I didn't think so far neither cool
a few months later he dished on how he's
handling her teenage years being a dad
of a 15 year old teenager oh my gosh I'm
I I know I hate I hate three people and
I haven't met them those were her first
boyfriends haven't met them yet but I
know I hate them
you
[Music]